شكرا على الاستضافه للاسف الوضع المتازم
والوضع الماساوي على مستوى مدى تازم الوضع
الانساني في شمال سوريا وحول سوريا هو ليس
وليدا اليوم هو كان وضع قائم بالفعل وعلى
امتداد سنوات النزاع وخاصه على امتداد
السنوات الاخيره التي شهد شهدت تراجع على
مستوى دعم وتمويل العمليات الانسانيه مما
خلق مزيد من الاحتياجات الطارئه خاصه في
مناطق الشماليه في سوريا اليوم نتحدث حول
سوريا هناك 15 مليون شخص من بين 18 مليون
مجموعه سكانهم في حاجه الى شكل من اشكال
المساعده الانسانيه وبالتالي ما يحصل
اليوم على خلفيه الزلزال المدمر هو فقط
تواصل لازمه انسانيه كانت قائمه بالفعل ما
يقدم اليوم
نقدمه اليوم كلجنه دوليه للصليب الاحمر
بالشراكه مع شريكنا الاساسي في سوريا وهو
الهلال الاحمر العربي السوري هو هو مجهود
متواضع بالمقارنه الى ما يحتاجه السكان
فعليا ومن الضروره ان
تتضافر كل جهود لتقديم المزيد من عمليات
الاغاثه الانسانيه في الاسابيع وفي
الفترات القادمه حاليا نركز على على دعم
الاحتياجات الاساسيه خاصه في الملاجئ
المؤقته من غذاء من اغطيه من لوازم
النظافه شخصيه من ادويه الى اخره وكذلك
نقوم بتاهيل
بعض الملاجئ المؤقته خاصه في مدينه حلب
على سبيل المثال بالكهرباء او بنقل المياه
الامنه ولكن كما ذكرت تبقى هذا نقطه في
بحر ما يحتاجه السكان يوميا في هذه
المناطق المنكوبه نعمل كذلك بالشراكه مع
وزاره الصحه على دعم المستشفيات الرئيسيه
خاصه في حماه حلب
والذي قيا بالمعدات الطبيه الاساسيه خاصه
المعدات التي من شانها ان ان تعالج الجرحى
اولئك الذين يعانون من جروح خطيره ومن
المنتظر ان نقوم
بايصال
لوازم اغاثه ومعدات اغاثه اضافيه هي تشق
طريقها حاليا يعني لكي تبلغ في الفترات
المقبله المناطق المنكوبه في شمال غرب
سوريا ولكن كما ذكرت تبقى الجهود التي
يقدمها كل الفاعلين الانسانيين اليوم نقطه
في بحر ما يحتاجه
السكان حاليا نحن نتحدث عن ازمه كانت
قائمه بالفعل كما ذكرتم من الضروري ان
تتواصل حمله التضامن التي نراها اليوم
مع سكان هذه المناطق ان تتواصل على
المستوى المتوسط والبعيد لاننا لا ننتظر
ان تتراجع هذه الاحتياجات الاساسيه خلال
الفترات المقبله بين العكس انتم ايضا في
الصليب الاحمر لا تستطيعون تقديم اي الا
من خلال معبر واحد هو معبر باب الهواء
مساعدات عبر الحدود اي معبر باب الهواء او
غيره من المعابر او المساعدات عن طريق
دمشق من الضروري اليوم ان لا تسيس ان لا
لا الاغاثات الانسانيه لانه مساله حياه او
موت بالنسبه لعشرات الالاف من الضروري ان
يضع كل الاطراف الاحترازات السياسيه على
جنب وان يتم التركيز فقط على الذات
البشريه وعلى المصلحه الانسانيه فقط الى
اي مدى استطعتم بالفعل صار هذه المساعده
خصوصا للقطاع الصحي يعني في شمال غرب
سوريا حلب اللاذقيه حماه وغيرها من
المناطق التي تضررت بشكل كبير اليوم والتي
تعاني اصلا انقطاعها الصحي سيد ايمن
نحن استعملنا في خلال الايام الفارطه قمنا
باستعمال الموارد التي كانت موجوده على
على عين المكان اي في سوريا ولكن قمنا
كذلك بتجنيد او
باستعمال المخزون الاضافي الذي هو موجود
في مناطق مجاوره ودول مجاوره على سبيل
المثال المعدات او اللوازم الانسانيه التي
تشق طريقها حاليا لكي تصل خلال الفتره
المقبله سوري المناطق المتضرره تم
ايصالها من مخازننا الموجوده في الاردن
ولكن كما ذكرت يعني يبقى يبقى كل هذا
المجهود
متواضع جدا مقارنه بما بما نسبه الاستجابه
التي يجب ان يقام بها من قبل كل الاطراف
الانسانيه اليوم في المنطقه المنكوبه الان
فيما بعد هذا الزلزال بالنظر الى
التداعيات الى اي مدى
ترون ان هناك
حاجه ملحه وعاجله لضمان امدادات مستدامه
للتعامل مع الواقع الماساوي الذي تعيش هذه
المناطق المنكوبه
اريد ان اشير انه خلال السنوات الاخيره
الازمه الانسانيه التي هي التي هي تسوء
حال من يوم كل يوم يعني
شهدت تراجع على مستوى الدعم الدولي خاصه
على المستوى التمويل عمليات الاغاثه حتى
اننا ان الازمه السوريه اصبح اصبحنا نشير
اليها بالازمه المنسيه اليوم بعد 12 سنه
من النزاع احتياجات السكان حول سوريا لا
تتلخص في في في امدادات اغاثه انيه او
استعجاليه كتقديم الغذاء وتقديم الماء
الصالح للشراب الى اخره هم يحتاجون الى
حلول بعيده المدى هم يحتاجون الى بنيه
تحتيه هم يحتاجون الى ابسط مقومات
العيش الكريم بما يعني ذلك من حصولهم على
الماء الصالح للشراب خدمات التطهير خدمات
الصحه الى اخره وبالتالي من الضروره ان
تستجيب عمليات الاغاثه له الاحتياجات
بعيده المدى الاحتياجات الاستعجاليه او
تقديم مواد الاغاثه او مواد التدفئه او
الغذاء لا يكفي
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
للاستجابه الى ما يحتاجه السكان فعليا من
الضروري اليوم ان يتم التفكير في مرحله ما
بعد الكارثه اي ان لا يتوقف التضامن فور
ما تتجه انظار العالم نحو نحو نحو خبر
ثاني او نخوه او نحوه اي تطورات تصير حول
العالم لن لا يكون التضامن مع القضيه
الانسانيه في سوريا مرتبطه بحدث اليوم
هناك ضروره بان يتواصل الدعم على المستوى
المتوسط والبعيد وما يقتضيه ذلك من مزيد
دعم الفاعلين الانسانيين
لقدرتنا على توفير هذه البرامج التي تهدف
بصفه رئيسيه على خلق جو يحمي الكرامه الب
وبالتالي من
طريقتنا على سبيل المثال الاستجابه لذلك
هو ان نركز على اعاده احياء او تاهيل
البنيه البنيه التحتيه الاساسيه التي اريد
ان اشير بانها منهاره او شبه منهاره حول
سوريا ولكن تبقى المناطق الشماليه هي
الاكثر تضررا بهذا بهذا
التدهور الشديد للبنيه التحتيه الاساسيه
السيده ايمان قلت بانه اللجنه الدوليه
للصليب الاحمر تعمل على تقديم مساعداتها
او تحاول يعني تقديم هذه المسانده اللازمه
للملاج التي تستقبل عدد كبير من اللاجئين
والنازحين المشكله هنا انه لا ملاجئ كافيه
ولا الكثير من المهجرين والسكان والاهالي
ينامون في العراء اليوم دون وجود ما يقيهم
هذا البرد القارس يعني
للاسف هذا حقيقي ولكن اريد الاشاره بان
ازمه النزوح في هذه المناطق هي ليست وليده
الزلزال يعني سوريا كانت بالفعل تعاني من
ازمه نزوح شديده خاصه في المناطق
الشماليه في سوريا هناك حوالي سبعه سبعه
مليون نازح داخل سوريا اليوم اي ان
المناطق التي ضربت بالزلزال كانت بالفعل
تعاني من ازمه نزوح داخلي واليوم ياتي هذا
الزلزال لكي يضيف على معاناه السكان اليوم
للاسف
الملاجئ الموجوده هي لا تستقبل كل كل
الناجحين او كل الذين فقدوا بيوتهم او
تهجروا من وراء الزلزال هناك ناس اليوم
يفترشون العراء او يبتون في سياراتهم
لانهم فقدوا بيوتهم او لانهم يخافون من ان
يرجعوا الى المباني التي لم تنهدم ولكنهم
ولكنها على وشك الان او يخافون من قيام
موجه ثانيه من
الزلزال يعني هذا ما ينقل الينا عن طريق
زملائنا ميدانيا للاسف هذه حقيقه وبالتالي
هنا اعيد ندائي بانه لا يجب ان يقف
التضامن حول
التضامن مع معاناه سكان هذه المنطقه منطقه
فورا انتهاء المرحله الاستعجاليه شكرا
جزيلا لك ايمان الطرابلس هي المتحدث باسم
اللجنه الدوليه للصليب الاحمر في الشرق
الاوسط